[Music]
he loves me i was like
we have a connection i was like oh my
god
maybe i'm not gay because i was like is
anyone else seeing this like this is
real
and then we we rapped and then my
manager and everyone was like
she's an actor she's really good
flash forward and darren is celebrating
20 years as a solo performer with the
release of poison blood a deeply
personal song that details his
experience with depression and suicidal
ideations
[Music]
the lyrics are so honest and they're so
raw why is it so important for you to
get this personal and share
your real authentic self with fans you
know i've always felt like i was being
honest with my lyrics way back in the
savage garden days
[Music]
it takes a special type of person to
need to get on stage and have strangers
scream for us in a case i came from a
you know a pretty troubled family but
i've always loved the fact that i've
been able to talk about my feelings
that's what my music has always been
throughout my entire career and being
able to talk about mental health has
unlocked this wonderful conversation
where so many people have just said
that's how i feel too
and i think that that can save lives i
really do
[Music]
you